after world war ii conflict between
major nations became much rarer yet in
1962 a large-scale land war broke out
between the people's republic of china
and the republic of india over these
lands and after the war this bit was
taken from india and became a part of
china but given how things were at the
time with the cold war and how unsure
the outcome was why did china invade
india so as of the 1960s the indian
chinese border looked like this and was
the result of careful consideration
between the two peoples and of course it
wasn't the border had been drafted by
britain in the early 20th century in an
agreement with tibetan china and by
agreement i mean dictat in which britain
declared the border between india and
china to be this and that tibet was now
a chinese puppet state the chinese
refused to accept this mostly because
they hadn't been invited to the
conference but the british didn't care
and considered it to be a done deal now
india gained its independence in 1947
and along with its freedom it also
gained a territorial dispute one which
was made worse when china ran tibet in
1951 and since it was one of india's
most important trading partners it
soured relations tensions rose until
1954 when india and china came to an
agreement in which they agreed to
respect each other's territorial
integrity and increase trade this was up
until 1960 when tibet was host to a
failed uprising and the crackdown
afterwards damaged india's ties in the
region the indian prime minister
jawaharlal nehru was critical of china's
response and gave shelter to those
fleeing the region this angered the
chinese government and its foreign
minister zhuang lai pushed for a
military response to do two things
one take this territory which was
populated largely by indians of chinese
descent and two dissuade india from
supporting any tibetan rebels in the
future as such spies were sent into
northern india to lay the groundwork for
an invasion and the chinese built up
infrastructure in the border regions and
started to move soldiers there the
indians fearing an escalation created
the forward policy which would build up
their border defenses and make india's
claim to the land indisputable they also
approached the western powers for
advanced weapons to defend themselves a
request that the west denied because
india was seen as being too soft and
communism as such the new delhi
government turned to the soviet union
who having fallen out with china was
happy to make an ally and damage a
former friend in october 1962 after
small-scale clashes between indian and
chinese forces 40 000 chinese soldiers
crossed into india here which itself
only had several thousand soldiers in
the region the chinese leadership wanted
a quick war because their military was
both unsure as to how well india was
prepared and also believed that they
couldn't win a war of attrition and
launching an attack in october was
useful too since soon after the fighting
began the united states and the soviet
union were too busy with a certain cuban
missile crisis to do anything about it
at first chyna performed well and pushed
into the area of ease and zhuan lai
pushed for peace negotiations which neru
rejected and a month after chinese
forces had crossed into india they had
reached the edge of china's claim to
territory and so they declared a
ceasefire meaning that the war was
effectively over because china didn't
want to push its luck and india wasn't
in a position to respond so in the end
this war had many long-term effects the
loss pushed india to modernize its
military and begin the development of
nuclear weapons and the snub by the west
pushed it closer to the ussr and
pakistan gained two went itself and
china settled their own disputes over
their common border which in turn pulled
pakistan away from the west since due to
the increased trade they'd gotten more
from beijing than they ever had from
washington or london which completely
changed the balance of power in the
region i hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching with a
special thanks to my patrons james
bissonette mr wolfe kelly moneymaker
skye chappelle jerry landon jordan
longley adam stalter corso wolf gareth
turner marvin cassell wyan hockey
captain cydog spencer lightfoot buggery
wiggly matthew shipley maggie paxkowski
aaron the white robert wetzel marcus
asner anthony beckett alex schwinn the
mug whopper gustav swan copper tone
spinning three plates moe winston
cayward charles the first ben evanson
and scottish trekkie